they say your network is your net worth
and they're right let's talk money all
we talk is money
all we talk is money all we talk is
money
[Music]
whether it's a simple happy hour event
or a multi-day business conference there
are some major no-nos
to be aware if you want to build your
network
and it starts even before you show up
number one
don't show up blind think like my
ex-girlfriend and be
snoopy do your research and see who's
going to be there
most events have a pre-attendee list so
if you don't look it up
you up before showing up figure
out these three things
who's going to be there who you want to
meet and who you
have to meet story time i met patrick
betdavid at a financial conference in
2012.
every year i would reach out to him
before the meeting just to make sure he
was going to be there
to try to carve out some time to meet up
i did this every year for
eight years straight until i finally
joined him here at vt
so my advice to you is be patient good
things take
time and being consistent is huge hot
tip
make sure you get in good with the
organizer of the event this is usually
the executive director
or the event coordinator that connection
will decide whether they invite you back
or whether your invitation gets lost in
the mail make them your best friend
number two don't show up late when it
comes to any old party it's fine to be
cool
and show up fashionably late but when it
comes to business events
get your ass there on time showing up
late to a networking event is as
fashionable as
socks and crocs time is money
you're there to meet people and build
relationships and that'll cost you big
time
if you showed up an hour after the event
started now you got to play catch up
eat drink meet and mingle all at the
same time
so be on time or be left behind number
three
don't be sloppy come correct dress like
your grandmother will see you make sure
you look good
feel good and get down to business don't
take this the wrong way
but look in the mirror buddy and call me
crazy but i recommend getting a second
opinion
on your attire story time this one time
this dude showed up at a networking
event with a mustache
growing out of his ear it looked like he
had a small hamster
trying to escape his eardrum this guy
clearly did not look in a mirror
possibly in years and no one told him
not his friends
not his colleagues not me i can assure
you no one wanted to sit down with this
hairy bastard
so the overall rule is don't be
disgusting
number four don't be shy confidence is
key introduce yourself
say your name loudly and have a firm
handshake leave the dead fish at home
shake their hand don't give them your
hand like you're a princess getting out
of a horse and carriage
and don't be afraid to say a joke or two
while you're there talk about your
surroundings
if it's too hot if it's too cold if the
soup doesn't look right
if you see something say something
nothing puts people at ease like a witty
observation
and while you're there put down your
phone don't be a middle schooler look at
sally in the eye
and make her feel special and remember
the guy who didn't say anything in the
back of the room
in high school no of course you don't
and no one does
because he's not memorable don't be that
person at the networking event
now's not the time to be or be visible
and
get in the mix network in the bar never
eat alone and don't network in the
bathroom
number five don't make it about you the
goal is to have a conversation
not to talk about yourself when someone
tells you something ask a follow-up
question
don't try to one-up them oh you're from
new york that's crazy because i was just
in new york and
here dude don't be that guy and no
basic networking etiquette ask questions
and listen more than you speak
you've got one mouth and two ears for a
reason and remember
the more you give the more you get be
john stockton
be an assist man you scratch my back i
scratch yours
make referrals and you'll receive
referrals and bring
something i bring golf balls with my
company logo on it i can't golf
for but it's not about me it's
about the people who i'm trying to reach
number six don't be an amateur this
isn't amateur hour you
gotta know your at some point
someone's gonna ask you about your
business
and you gotta have your elevator pitch
ready and don't
disparage competitors that's a rookie
move bro say something like
yeah they do a good job but here's why
we're better that's having class
instead of being an ass and number seven
don't blow it in the end master the exit
always do a final lap you'll never know
who you're gonna meet at the end
yeah it's important to get the early but
i think it's better to leave
late people always remember the last
thing they've heard
and know how to say goodbye your goal is
to establish a relationship
not make a sale get a number or a
business card so you can follow up
don't be too aggressive like that drunk
guy at the end of the bar
you're looking for a long-term
relationship not a one-night stand
and once the meeting is over follow
up you can do everything right but if
you don't follow up
there's no point in showing up
networking is where the conversation
begins
not where it ends my two cents
networking is so underrated you can get
rich just by having the right
conversation with the right person
my favorite book of all time is how to
win friends and influence people
the biggest lesson in this book is that
you have to have a genuine interest
in other people every business is the
people business
it's all about relationships who you
know will get you in the door
and what you know will keep you there be
authentic be prepared and create
lasting connections it's been said that
you are the direct reflection
of the five people you hang out with the
most so who you hanging out with
thanks for watching this video on
networking what was your biggest
takeaway
let me know below in the comments and as
always save that money
all we talk is money all we talk
talk is